first it's hunter to face carson kelly
leading off tommy hunter now 34 years
old well traveled
last year with the phillies 24 games in
relief he had knocked out in his
contract that's needed to call him up
this week or he could have declared his
free agency they called him up and now
he's pitching for the second time in two
days
and it's lifted along the right field
line conforto coming over to the stripe
and reaching and makes a terrific catch
right before he got to that short wall
boy conforto has made some fine plays
over the last few days and that was yet
another well he made one last night i
mean this is just fearless play right
there by michael
he knows that that short wall is a real
impediment if you hit it standing up you
can really flip and hurt yourself
so he got into the slide got his glove
in the perfect position made a terrific
play yeah he got his hands in front of
him after the catch which stopped and
cushioned him from that face hitting
that mat so here's david peralta and
hunter is going to stay in to face him
peralta scorches one and alonso makes a
terrific play to end the inning now the
mets playing some defense in that first
inning for hunter
joey casey is the bulk guy tonight you
know so far it's been kind of a struggle
as a starting pitcher for joey lucasy 12
runs in his eight and two thirds innings
pitch time to get it going his last four
starts when he was with the padres
against the d-backs he was one-on-one
with a 2-7-5
castro hitting eighth in the order gotta
watch the bunt with his speed and the
syracuse native lifts one to shallow
center long run for pilar diving and he
made the catch
[Applause]
[Music]
very nice
i haven't seen a guy who's able to leap
and keep his eye on the ball
since eric burns used to do that many
moons ago so you have to take a chance
with the count in your favor of bouncing
one down and in see here phil offer to
get the strikeout seventh pitch of the
advantage walker got him looking
fastball in the inside corner lucasie
puts down trouble in the third here's
mcneil of flight out his first time up
on goal one strike pitch
mcneal slams one to deep right center
field headed toward the bullpen it's out
of here
jeff mcneal with his third home run of
the year a two-run shot puts the mets on
top that's as hard as jeff mcneal has
hit a ball all season you mentioned it
earlier keith how well he's done out of
that lead off spot and lindor instantly
celebrating
lendore runs kelly start a second it
goes into center field and lindor will
go to third he might be able to score he
takes the turn he's heading home he's
going to score without a throw francisco
lindor his first stolen base is amen and
he comes all the way around as the ball
deflects into the outfield
and the mets laid it three nothing
career stolen base number 100 and it
comes with a little extra juice well the
worm could be turning here folks
not a good throw from the catcher
kelly and the ball just carens out there
no man's land and maybe the worm is
starting to turn so stolen base for
lindora career steal number 100 number
one is a match david peralta two balls
two strikes
on the outside corner and lucasie gets
peralta looking that's a strike
nice framing by
mccann let's see here this will not lie
uh it's a strike about the front edge
that's painter wagon casey from the wind
up first pitch coming
hillar comes racing in sliding and he
made another catch kevin pillar just
showing off made a dive to rob la castro
in the last inning now a slide to take a
hit away from cabrera two out well in
order to show off gary you gotta have
the opportunities an outfit are gonna go
whole nine innings and not get a ball
hit him
and pillars had two plays in front of
him
in the first four innings of this game
nice plays both of them gets great jumps
on both of those balls
here's escobar
and he got him with a breaking ball
casey strikes out escobar and he's got
himself a one two three inning with some
help from pillar three-nothing mets in
the fourth well around the corners
nobody out for david peralta who has
grounded out struck out over two
chops that one to short
the r is over there from third
and now they've got
walker scrambling back to the bag and
the diamondbacks are on the board last
five games for familia five and four and
third it's only given up two hits and no
runs the mets bullpen in the last 50 odd
innings has been outstanding earliest
entry of the year for familia coming on
with one out of the sixth to face us
dribble cabrera and he struck him out
went upstairs with the fastball that
time to get as dribble for the second
out
familia has done a very good job of this
this year if you notice that he goes
down in the strike zone and when he
needs to strike uh strikeout he'll
counter with a four seam up in the
strike zone
o2 coming to escobar
struck him out
nasty familiar with back-to-back
strikeouts to limit the damage in the
sixth diamondbacks will have the
merry-go-round in motion
smith kelly and rojas will all be moving
with the pitch
he'll see a seventh pitch with all the
runners set to go
3-2 from familia to walker
round ball right at lindor
high throw alonzo stayed on the bag side
retired that was an adventure
linder almost lost it then he sailed the
throw alonzo saves him an error and
familia finds his way out of trouble in
the seventh
wow
still 3-1 new york here's mcneal who has
the biggest hit in this game a two-run
homer in the third
and mcneil tacks one back to the mound
davinski to second for one the relay not
in time
so they get the 1-6 fielders choice for
the first out one away with lindor
coming up
and he breaks his bat bloops it into
center coming on is smith and drops in
for a hit mcneil reddit will he heads
home and he will score
a broken bat hit for lindor produces a
run on the mets laid at 4-1 so the
stolen base helps produce a run even
boat batting 205 on the year does have
three home runs cabrera is at second
aumented first
even vote with a base hit that rolls
into right center here comes his drobo
ahmed chugging into third and the
diamondbacks have cut the lead in half
it's four to two
boys steven not an easy at bat for a
left-handed hitter against luke but
stays right in there gets that ball on
the barrel finds that hole on the right
side you can see how deep mcneal was
playing out in the shallow right field
lynn door was also on that side of the
bag but steven bangs it right through
him that's put on the full shift against
david peralta with kelly at first and
two down
driven to right conforto is there and
the ball game is over the mets win their
fourth in a row